in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Kyle
and Shana are with us hey guys how are
ya good days thanks welcome welcome
where do you live
Charlottesville Virginia Oh fine that's
a pretty Drive this time yeah eight
hours yeah eight hours a lot of leaves a
lot of there's a lot of mountains
between your dinner yeah very nice cool
well welcome to Nashville and you're
here to do a debt-free screen all right
how much have you paid off
one hundred and one thousand sixty six
dollars and 79 cents I love it and how
long did that take 22 months whoa while
cash flowing five thousand dollars for
my knee surgery and our wedding whoa
there's that yeah okay and your
household income range during that time
started at about 70 and right now about
150 at the last six months of paying off
our debt Wow very good and so your what
do you guys do for a living we're both
cardiovascular technologists I work in
the cardiac cath lab where can
electrophysiology lab so I'm guessing
one of you finished school went to work
during this time that's where the income
change came from yeah okay and I'm also
going to guess and say you got married
about 22 months ago or somewhere in the
last 22 months you mentioned a wedding
so I'm cheating but yeah so how long you
been married here and a half a year and
a half together ten years in January
okay Wow and so before the wedding you
both looked at this and said we've got
to clean this up and I've got knee
surgery and we got to pay for the
wedding
yes and you went after it so one hundred
and one thousand two years everybody did
you have some money stored or something
I did for that my grandfather left me a
CD when he passed and that helped pay
mostly 90% of the wedding okay how much
how much was that about eight thousand
yeah eight or nine thousand okay so what
you spent like ten twelve thousand
dollar wedding okay and we also decided
to do a monetary gift for our wedding
and our bridal shower yeah okay and how
much did you collect from that Hall
twelve thousand Oh that helped out a lot
very nice we didn't even buy anything we
just put it right towards the car
way to go friends and family I like it
so
the 101 was car and what else student
loans furniture family loan my beautiful
ring yes oh wow yeah yeah you were just
like normal
Zach so what happened that made the
switch flip that made you go okay we're
going to go bananas here cuz I mean you
guys you went all in on this oh yeah so
when we first moved to Charlottesville
we Shana's car died and we had to she to
get it we didn't get a new car for her
of granny of course a new court already
ours of course so the same about the
same time we also got furniture we had
to get new furniture and moving a new
apartment and also the engagement ring
at the same time so all those things had
added up and then eventually our student
loans came came due so then my sister
was actually in town right around right
around when we were buying all this
stuff and she said to me have you ever
heard of Dave Ramsey after I told her
how much we you know how much debt we
just think you know acquires and she and
we said no and she said you should read
this book yes you're being stupid yeah
that's a nice way or your sister saying
that that's pretty funny yeah so
thankful she did yeah so you read the
Total Money Makeover in like a day yeah
and then continue to listen employer
yeah yeah
something you did like a 180 you went
from like we're buying everything on
debt and 20 minutes later we're paying
it all off just like that exactly the
podcast every day before work we're
pretty obsessed yeah so what was the
weirdest cheapo thing you did during
this 22 months to make this happen I
mean total monetary gifts that the
weddings playing weird that's probably
like that one but what about it what's
another one that you did mm what do you
think just saying no a lot I guess
other people that was weird yeah you
know what is your sister say when you
guys did all this he's so proud of us
she's upset about this this morning and
she was telling us how proud she is I
guess cheerleader of all yeah very cool
did you have other friends or family
make fun of you hell yeah oh yeah got it
but now they're starting to like I agree
with us on where we're coming from yeah
yeah that's a lot of thousand dollars
how you like me now oh yeah I like it
that's very good very cool very good
nice nice so what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is definitely
the budget I don't know how we would
ever be able to do it without the budget
how how do you guys uh in your situation
looking in from the outside just hearing
your story one of the things that got
you out of that was yours in Tim yes
exactly what did that intensity come
from we just kept talking about our
goals
yeah just our future we've been together
for so long that I feel like a lot of
our goals are very common I feel like we
work very well as a team and it kind of
turned into like a game yeah how much
can we pay off this month how much go
pay after next yeah and the but like
every single month we know how much
money we would make to like to the cent
we would write it all down and I
honestly think that's the best thing
anyone could do yeah yeah it's very cool
so yeah the budget is the vehicle but
salutely man you guys were both just
completely game on tons of overtime and
everything we could do that's I copied
it up yeah well it's neat though I mean
in only 22 months my mom you're done I
mean that's just very good very cool
very well done well I'm proud of you
guys thank you
very neat how old are you - 25 and she's
26 just oh man awesomeness very neat
very neat very cool man you cook so well
150 grand coming in at 26 years old and
no payments how's it feel it's amazing
it's like the best feeling ever if we I
feel like we're really in control which
i think is the best plus you two have
learned that if you bond together like
that and get intense you can do anything
yeah I mean there's nothing that's going
to come your way you can't knock it out
how are you that's the truth it's very
well done and thank you so much we
really appreciate you you are such a
lifesaver to so many people everything
you do thank you I appreciate it we're
honored to get to us
watch heroes like you win man you guys
are incredible so we've got a copy of
Chris Hogan's retire inspired book
thanks we always do and that's signed by
him because that's the next chapter in
this story you're going to become very
wealthy and you're going to be
outrageously generous and we're going to
show you how to do that next chapter so
very cool all right Kyle and
Shana's Charlottesville Virginia a
hundred and one thousand dollars paid
off in 22 months plus a wedding in a
surgery seventy thousand one hundred and
fifty income counted down
let's hear a debt free scream
I love it
I love it I love it I love it Wow very
cool YouTube very very cool now there
was a lot of stuff in that story if you
were listening a lot of you've asked me
a hundred times you know I got a family
member that is kind of being stupid how
do I talk to him about it his sister man
walks up and goes hey her Dave Ramsey
she never she didn't go in there and go
you're stupid buying that car you're
stupid buying that ring you're stupid by
the virtue she just said hey you might
want to look at some other way of doing
stuff and you know that that soil was
fertile and she planted seed in it and
the this young couple grabbed ahold of
it and changed their lives
Amy his sister gets a lot of credit
there if you got somebody in your life
you're supposed to be talking to not
about Dave Ramsey that's not the subject
it's okay if you say Dave Ramsey I don't
care but I mean I'm not trying to get
the credit that's not the point the
point is are you is there somebody in
your life that's being stupid and you
got to have the courage to say hey hey
hey hey have you ever thought about not
being normal
not being deeply in debt your whole life
have you ever thought about hey read
this book let me give you a total money
makeover book let me send you the
Financial Peace University I'll take
care of it is there somebody in your
life you're supposed to do that for and
again I'm not trying to sell a book of
the class I'm okay folks I'm believe me
I'm gonna be all right
I'm everything's okay at the Ramsey
House if we don't sell another book
we're gonna be all right you know but
the point is is that there's it's a way
to have this discussion and it's a way
to influence somebody that you care
about for their own good that's
something to think about there's a lot
in that story and did you hear that the
way that the both of them got on board
and both of them were intense and both
of them were focused there's a high
correlation and married couples between
those that are able to build wealth and
those that are able to work together
when one married one member of the
marriage is not willing to work to win
it's very difficult because you are
dragging along little lord fauntleroy
with you the prince who's a - he's -
entitled to work or little princess a
little snow-white there she doesn't want
to work she's a princess she doesn't
want to sacrifice to win but buddy went
to sharp young people like that get on
board and they lean into it
oh my changes everything by the way it
works for old people - hey this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show